Well, good morning again, church.
Uh, it's great to see you, uh, what a week it's been, right?
Like, uh, it's hard
to get motivated when it's zero degrees outside.
So I'm glad it's gonna be 65 today.
I'm glad we're here together as well.
Also, I'm really glad and thankful, uh,
for criss cross jumping in last Sunday, doing a great job
with the series in one Samuel.
So we're gonna keep going in that today.
So take your copy of God's word, turn with me to chapter 23
of one Samuel one, Samuel 23 is
where we're gonna continue today.
So where I was last weekend, I was on a ski trip
with my oldest son, uh, 16-year-old on Christmas Eve.
And so, uh, just like I did, if you remember years ago,
I did those 10 trips with our sons, the big trips.
And so I'm gonna do a, a 16 trip with each of them
as well just to go skiing together.
Uh, well, lemme just tell
you a little bit about what happened.
One, one day at the top of the lift,
we're getting off the lift
and there's a big group of people kind of gathered
around one of the ski patrol members
and that ski patrol guy was showing them how to, uh, like
what to do if you get stranded basically.
And so, uh, he was showing them how to dig like a, a,
an igloo out of the side of a snowbank.
So if you're back country skiing and you get lost
and stranded, how to stay warm, right?
So you dig this hole in there and, and it has a, a vent
and you keep your body heat inside.
It actually can stay pretty warm, supposedly.
I don't wanna try that, but it, it can do that.
And so that was what he was showing them to do.
Now again, I'm never gonna ski in a place
that I'll actually need, that they've caught
an avalanche or anything.
I'm not gonna do that. But if, if I was in that situation
or if someone is in that situation, that place in a time
of trouble would be a refuge, right?
It would be a place that they would find shelter
in their time of need.
Well, we've observed recently in one Samuel
that David has needed a refuge
as King Saul has come
after him trying to take his life jealously.
David needed a refuge.
In fact, he needed not just a refuge, he needed a deliverer.
He needed someone to save him.
Well, what we're gonna see today is God's providence in
and over David's life, meaning
God's sovereign control of events
and people to bring about his purposes.
But we're also gonna see not only God's providence,
we're gonna see God's deliverance in David's life in order
to continue God's purpose through
and in David, which will point us to
that same God in our lives when we face
similar circumstances.
So let's pray. First, let's ask God to teach us what we need
to learn in this passage.
So Father God, we do come to you humbly.
What a miracle that we can even do this right now,
that by your grace, the God of the universe, God almighty,
you allow us to just come right into your presence like
this, to speak to you
as if you're sitting across the table from us.
God, what a gift privilege that is.
And you've given us your word to tell us about yourself.
And so, Lord, we pray you'd show us today something
from your word about who you are, what you have done,
what you will do, that we can be impacted
and changed forever because of it.
We need you to do that. God, we can't do that ourselves.
And so we trust you will give us eyes to see it.
Give us a heart ready to receive it. In Jesus' name. Amen.
So as we've progressed through the book of Samuel, uh,
first Samuel, you can see that this has been a journey right
as we've moved from Samuel to Saul, to now David.
And this shift is happening from Saul to David.
As as God's moving
and the people are beginning to popularize David
and Saul's losing credibility, all of that's happening.
Uh, we saw the, the only remaining
priest aligned with David.
So Saul has lost all of that.
We've also learned that David's trying
to grow in his ability to seek the Lord
and trust the Lord in all circumstances.
Through the trials, all the persecution,
God is bringing David closer to himself.
Well, at this point now in the narrative,
David's back in Judah, he's actually not far from
where Saul was.
And so what we're now learning as we go forward here is
that the tension is being heightened.
And we've seen this interaction, David and Saul
before many times now.
But the tension is heightening
as things are getting further down the road.
And so we're gonna read the whole section here,
starting in verse 15, chapter 23, verse 15 through verse 29,
and going to give the whole picture.
And so David saw that Saul had come out to seek his life.
David was in the wilderness as if at Horsch.
And Jonathan Saul's son rose and went to David at Horsch
and strengthened his hand in God.
Jonathan said to him, do not fear for the hand of Saul.
My father shall not find you. You shall be king over Israel.
I shall be next to you Saul. My father also knows this.
And the two of them made a covenant before the Lord.
David remained at hoes and Jonathan went home.
Then the Z fights, remember that's where David was.
The Z fights went up to Saul at GIAs saying,
it's not David hiding among us in the strongholds
of Horsch on the hill of Haah, which is south of Jmo.
Now come down O King according
to all your heart's desire to come down.
And our part shall be to surrender David into your hand.
And Saul said, may you be blessed by the Lord,
for you've had compassion on me.
Go make yet more sure know
and see the place where his foot is.
See, uh, who has seen him there for?
It's told me that he's very cunning.
See therefore take note
of all the lurking places where he hides.
Come back to me with sure information,
then I will go with you.
If he's in the land, I'll search him out
among all the thousands of Judah.
And they arose and went to Ziff ahead of Saul.
Now David and his men were in the wilderness
of May in the ABA to the south of YesOn.
And Saul and his men went to seek him. And David was told.
So he went down to the rock,
lived in the wilderness of Mayon.
When Saul heard that he pursued
after David in the wilderness of Mayon,
Saul went on one side of the mountain, David
and his men on the other side of the mountain.
And David was hurrying to get away from Saul.
As Saul and his men were closing in on David
and his men to capture them.
A messenger came to Saul saying, hurry come.
The Philistines have made a raid against the land.
So Saul returned from pursuing after David
and win against the Philistines.
Therefore, that place was called the Rock of Escape.
And David went up from there,
lived in the strongholds of in gti.
Now, if you were here last week
or you caught up online, this passage, this back half
of chapter 23 is structured very similarly to the first half
that Chris talked about last week.
In fact, it's merely the same concepts.
It just expands on them a little more deeply.
And David did get delivered in the first section from
Saul's uh, efforts.
But here in this section, we not only see the deliverance,
we see the reasons behind the deliverance, the big, why
did God deliver David and even how in many ways.
So we'll uncover that as we work through the passage.
But first we saw in verses 15 through 18 that God used
Jonathan to deliver David in this scene.
First God used Jonathan, the same Jonathan
that was Saul's son, right?
Who had aligned with David.
Now God used Jonathan to deliver David,
but what did Jonathan deliver David from?
Because in their scene they're back and forth.
There's no battle there. There's no like
near death experience.
So what happened here?
Why did I say that Jonathan delivered David?
Well, he delivered David from fear.
God used Jonathan to deliver David from fear.
'cause you can imagine that David would've been tempted
to be quite afraid, right?
He's faced with all of this, this king
who's putting all his resources into killing you.
Like that. That's a terrifying thing.
He would have reason to be afraid.
And you can go read the Psalms that David wrote
around these scenes and you, you see real fear in his life.
All these threats. We even saw it in
the way David acted at times.
Remember he was, he was trusting his own cunningness rather
than trusting God.
He was trying to manipulate situations 'cause he was afraid.
Even Jonathan's words here in verse 17, he comes to David,
the first thing he says, do not fear
'cause he knew David would've been afraid.
But Jonathan came with a goal.
Verse 16 says, Jonathan's goal was to strengthen
David's hand in God.
What that means is to encourage him, stay confident,
stay steadfast, encourage him to keep going
in this towards the Lord.
He knew David needed that.
Now, it's not the first time something like this
is said in the Bible.
The prophet Isaiah said something very similar
to God's people.
In Isaiah 35, those who were waiting on God to return,
they felt like things were falling apart.
Isaiah 35, here's what it says. Strengthen the weak hands.
Make firm the feeble knees.
Say to those who have an anxious heart.
Be strong fear, not behold your God will come
with vengeance, with the recompense of God.
He will come and save you. Is that not what David needed?
He needed someone to strengthen him.
He needed to be reminded that God was going
to win this battle, that God was actually working
in this moment.
And so God used Jonathan to deliver David from fear.
But notice how he did it. How did Jonathan do it?
He did it through identity.
God used Jonathan to deliver David from fear
through identity.
Look again at one Samuel 23 verse 17.
This is what Jonathan said to David.
He said, do not fear for the hand of Saul.
My father shall not find you. You shall be king over Israel.
I shall be next to you Saul, my father even knows this.
In other words, Jonathan looks at David
who's in this tough spot, terrified.
He looks at David and he says,
Hey David, remember who you are.
Remember who God anointed you to be.
Remember who God is,
but don't forget that strong He God is strong enough
to protect you to accomplish this plan.
He told you it's gonna happen. Trust him.
Remember who he said you're going to be like He.
He reminded David of the identity that God had given him.
Everyone else knew it. Even King Saul himself knew
that David was anointed as the next king.
David could have very easily been forgetting that
he's in the moments of death facing him
and he's getting spears thrown at him.
He's hiding in the wilderness.
He's like, did God, are you sure?
Like, is this really gonna work out? I'm not totally sure.
This looks like it will.
So David needed to be reminded
of those truths he needed to be reminded.
So let's just think about this for a second.
You see any parallels to our lives?
You, you see how this could maybe relate
to our situation at all.
You and I are so prone to this where we as
Christians, instead of remembering who we are in Christ,
we're so prone to re just rest in the lies
or be swayed by the circumstances instead of remembering
who we are in Christ.
I mean, just think about how this works out, right?
You, you compare your financial situation
to someone else who's just one rung
above you on that ladder.
And then you start to somehow question that God is,
are you really providing for me
when you're fine, see how that works?
God, are you really the provider? God, am I really yours?
Are you really caring for me?
This is how it works out for me.
Someone criticizes me in, in my position and,
and I can easily begin to think
that I am actually pretty worthless.
Or you struggle with past sins and,
and you're doubting your forgiveness.
It just comes back up.
You're like, man, am I really forgiven for that?
It just feels like I'm not.
And what that does is just gives the enemy a chance
to keep condemnation on your shoulders over and over again.
Or someone mocks the decisions you've made
to live a holy life.
'cause you'd say, I can't live the world the way the world,
I'm gonna try to live God's way.
And, and somebody mocks that.
And so in your heart, you start to compromise a little bit
to try not to look as foolish to the world.
All of that and so much more is why you
and I need to regularly be reminded of who we
Are in Christ.
See you. You'll hear us talk about it.
Almost every church you are ever a part
of will talk about the importance
of things like studying God's word, praying, getting
with your church family, worshiping together, small groups,
godly friends, all of that.
Why do we talk about that?
I is it just because we are legalistic
and we want you to do certain things
or control you in certain ways?
No, it's because those things are what remind you
of your identity in Christ.
I It's not to control. It's like we want better for you.
I I need those things in my life. I need God's word.
I need to pray. I need people like you to remind me of
who I am whenever I start to question it.
Because it's so easy to forget that.
It's so easy to doubt that.
And listen, when I'm talking identity here,
when we say this identity thing, I'm not talking about
what you do, even
David in a sense, right?
Like I, I am a doctor or I am a teacher.
No, that's what you do. It's not who you are.
Those things can easily change, right?
Like you, you can grow up and get a degree in this and
and work something completely different.
You can be this for 12 years
and then all of a sudden you change, do something else.
That's not who you are, right? That's what you do.
Who you are is that unchangeable part of you.
And predominantly what we're talking about in
that if you're a Christian, your identity is child of God.
That's Unchangeable, right?
That doesn't matter what you're doing, what you do
for a vocation or hobby or what, it's who you
Are.
And so hear me if that's you,
if you've trusted in the life, death,
and resurrection of Jesus in your place,
Then Let me just remind you for a second who you are.
Let me remind you of what God says about you.
And, and I don't know this,
this came really late in the week.
So I, I'm assuming God led this to happen
because somebody in this room needs to hear
What I'm about to say.
I needed to hear this. Lemme remind you of who
You are a Christian.
Just listen carefully. Let this soak into your soul.
You Are a saint made holy
By Christ's blood. You are blessed
Because of God's presence in your life.
God takes delight in you even singing over
You.
You are saved forever.
Not by any work you could ever do in your life,
but by Christ work for you.
You are reconciled with the God of the universe.
You will experience trouble in this life,
but Christ has overcome that trouble for you.
You have access to God all the time.
You are gifted by God's spirit for his purpose.
You are a new creation in Christ.
You will sin yes,
but you are fully forgiven
underneath the perfect blood of Jesus.
Us you're chosen
and adopted into God's very family.
You're not finished yet,
but you are not what you used to be.
And you are fully complete in Christ.
In Christ. You have the victory over sin and death.
You are loved far more than you can even imagine
and so much more.
I could keep going for days and talk about that.
But let me remind you if that's your identity,
that means no criticism, no situation, no temptation,
no lie can change any of that.
Christian. That's who you are.
Be reminded of that. That's your new identity in Christ.
That's not like something you hope to be.
That's what God's word says.
That's what you are right now, No matter
what anybody else says, no matter what your flesh says,
no matter what the enemy of our souls says,
that means you can live a no fear kind of life
because of that identity.
Romans 8 31, if God is for us who can be against us?
No fear because that's who God says you are.
I don't know who needed that. I did.
So Jonathan
was used by God to deliver David from the fear
that was naturally coming in his life
because of his situation.
There was fear, but God said through Jonathan, here's Ray,
remember, don't forget you will be the king
because you are mine.
But here's the other thing. God used the Philistines
to deliver David as well.
So God used Jonathan to deliver David from fear,
but God used the Philistines to deliver David.
Now you're sitting there thinking like,
wait, wait a second, hold up.
Those are the enemy, right?
Like that's the bad guys in the story.
What is going on here?
Well that's part of the point
that God is fully in control of everything,
even enemy armies.
So what happened here? Someone ratted David out again
told Saul where David was hiding.
We don't know why. Maybe they were afraid of Saul
and they wanted to get on his good side, I don't know.
But they knew as Saul wanted to kill David.
So they told Saul where David was.
But this is an interesting piece.
Did you notice the depth of Saul's depravity?
Look at this verse 21.
They told Saul where David was
and Saul said, may you be blessed by the Lord
for you have had compassion on me.
Like he said, they showed him compassion by telling him
where David was hiding so he could go kill him.
Like Saul was still under this delusion that somehow
he's following God's plan for the the nation of Israel.
Like he was so far gone.
Well, thankfully David figured it out.
And so he went to hide even further in the wilderness and,
and as Saul continued
to pursue David even further in the wilderness, look again,
verse 26 starting here.
Saul went on one side of the mountain and David
and his men on the other side of the mountain
and David was hurrying to get away from Saul.
And Saul is and his men closing in on David
and men to capture them.
A messenger came to Saul saying, hurry
and come for the Philistines have made a raid
against the land.
So Saul returned from pursuing.
David went against the Philistines.
Therefore that place was called the rock of escape.
And so you see what just happened here, right?
God used the Philistines to deliver David from Saul
by bringing this diversion,
he brought a diversion, right?
God used the Philistines to deliver David from Saul
through a diversion
Like Saul had committed all of his resources to chase David
neglecting his primary responsibility was
to protect the nation.
And so this guy's coming like, Hey, hey Saul.
The Philistines are about to win.
And so he was forced to abandon the hunt, go back
to the primary battle he was supposed to.
Again, God used the Philistines to deliver David like the,
the enemy army to deliver David from Saul.
Now I know what you're thinking right now.
Some of you were skeptical about that. Like, ah, come on.
Really? That's just a coincidence.
I mean that's not really God's doing.
It doesn't actually say God did that.
Well, here's how we know. Look back up at verse 14,
the very last verse of the previous section,
the end of that says, Saul sought David every day,
but God did not give David into his hand.
It wasn't coincidence.
See that it was the Lord who was David's helper
David, in this seemingly inescapable situation.
But despite Saul's effort,
God did not give David into Alsan.
It was God. God was the one protecting,
sustaining David.
And David acknowledges this in Psalm 54.
This is the Psalm that David wrote in the midst
of this moment, Psalm 54 verse four, behold
God is my helper.
The Lord is the upholder of my life.
Like David himself knew.
He is like he wasn't his military ability to get
around if he wasn't just 'cause he was faster than.
So it was God upheld his life.
So again, God used Jonathan to deliver David from fear
through identity reminding him
of God's sure promise in his life.
This is who God says you are.
And God used the Philistine army to deliver David from Saul
through this diversion.
So what does this all leave us with then?
In other words, like what do we learn here? Like okay, what?
What's the point of this?
Why do we have this here? How does this apply to us?
Well, let me offer you two ways.
I'm sure you can find more, but but just two ways to today
and and these are truths I believe we need to hold onto
as we walk into similar situations in our lives.
Here's the first truth. Like David,
we have the same providential God in whom we can trust.
We today, Christian, we have the same
providential God in whom to trust.
Now we don't use that word providence very much in our day.
Here's what that big word means. It.
It means that God not only created everything, he also
oversees it and sustains it even down
to the tiniest little details of
Life.
That's providence.
Here's how the Westminster shorter catechism hundreds
of years ago defines it.
Providence is God's most holy, wise
and powerful preserving
and governing all his creatures and all their actions.
So we talk about God as sovereign means He's in control.
Providence means he's actively working
to bring about his purpose in everything.
And this is one of the great teachings of the Bible.
And hear me, it's not meant for us to sit here
and just simply conflict over it, theological debate over it
and and worry about it.
It's meant to be a source of comfort to us.
See if this is who God was for David.
And if God never changes,
that means today He sustains us
just as much as he did for
David.
If we are his, he sustains us just as he did for David.
The same God who is at work
to accomplish his purposes in David's life is the same God
who has continued
to work in his people throughout all the generations.
And what that means is that we can trust that God's purposes
and God's plan will be fulfilled in our lives.
We can trust it. The Bible is clear
that all of our days are counted out
by God, that we will not live
one second more
or one second less than what he has ordained for us to live.
There's a great sanctity of life passage in Psalm 1 39.
And I want you to listen to this the way it says
it for you.
God formed my inward parts.
You knitted me together in my mother's womb.
I praise you for I am fearfully and wonderfully made.
Wonderful are your works. My soul knows it very well.
My frame was not hidden from you when I was being made in
secret, intricately woven in the depths of the earth.
Your eyes saw my unformed substance.
Hear this in your book were written every one
of them the days that were formed
For me When as yet there were none
Of them.
Now that truth does not give us freedom
to be foolish and unwise
and take unnecessary risks in our lives like
skiing in an avalanche area.
Like yeah, God's got me.
You know, and you get buried, right?
Like that's not what you're supposed to do with that.
But it does mean it.
It does mean that we can trust that God's purpose
and plan will be fulfilled in our lives.
He's providentially working it out.
So whatever comes our way, God's got it.
He is in control. He is overseeing it. Here's the point.
Since God upholds our lives,
We don't have to live in fear.
Since the Lord upholds our lives,
he's providential in all things.
That means we don't have to fear, we don't have
to worry about what could come.
We don't have to worry about the ramifications of
what might happen over there.
Like we just don't worry because he is in control.
Elizabeth Elliot, incredible woman of God said it this way.
Fear arises when we imagine everything depends on
Us.
Fear
Arises when we imagine everything depends on us, right?
Isn't that true? You, I, I gotta control this.
I can't control this, so I'm afraid, right?
You're not in control. I'm not in control.
When I have this illusion, I'm in control.
That's whenever fear happens.
'cause I feel like I can't control that
Or this. And so
Thankfully We have a God who
Filters everything through His hands,
Who is in full control of everything, in everyone.
He is absolutely providential.
And because he is working out a much bigger plan than
merely my comfort, we can trust
that he will use whatever comes in our lives
For his glory and for our good.
You think about David's life, man,
there was some mystery in how God was working this out.
David wasn't always clear how this was gonna play out.
He kind of knew from the beginning what was,
but he like, this doesn't look right.
This doesn't look the way I think it should.
But God's promises to him we're certain
It's the same for us Today.
We have the same providential God
that we can trust in just like David did.
So let's trust him right?
When we face things, let's trust him.
But there's a second truth we can learn here too.
We learned this truth. And you may have,
we've talked about this a little bit when we put on our
Jesus goggles and we look at the Old Testament
through those lenses like Jesus did in Luke, where he said,
all of this points to me, we, we put on those glasses
and we look through the lens to the Old Testament, to
what Jesus shows up, how he shows up there.
We see it that way. So here's follow this.
Look at how this plays out in in verse 25.
Where does, where does it say that David went to hide,
he went to hide in the rock
in in verse 26.
What was it that hid him from Saul?
It was the mountain rock.
It was that mountain. Verse 28 says, was renamed
the rock of escape?
Maybe. See where this is going.
It Was the rock
that God used to save.
David,
here's, here's what you need to know.
Here's what we need to remember.
That's still how God works today.
The difference though is
that we have a greater rock in which to hide
and notice that R is capitalized.
We have a greater rock in which we can hide.
See the rocks that sheltered David were merely granite
or sandstone or whatever rock formation it was.
And yes, God used those rocks
to save David from Saul.
But the rock I'm referring to is found in Psalm one 18,
verse 22, 1
of the most quoted scriptures in the New Testament.
It's this verse pointing us to Christ.
It says this, the stone that the builders
rejected has become the cornerstone.
So no offense to Dwayne Johnson.
This is the true rock, right?
This is the rock, the cornerstone of our faith.
The most important piece of the entire foundation.
The cornerstone Jesus is the dividing line of salvation.
The only solid rock on which we can build our lives
that will last forever.
He's the Isaiah 26 Everlasting rock of ages,
the secure foundation of our lives.
He's the one Deuteronomy 32 calls the rock
whose work is perfect.
All his ways are justice without iniquity. He's faithful.
He's the one the Psalms refer to as the rock
and my fortress, my deliverer, my God in whom I take refuge,
my shield, the horn of my salvation, my stronghold.
He is the one, one Corinthians 10 calls the rock as Christ.
He is the one we come to for living water.
The one we come to for eternal water.
The one we come to whose foundation will not be shaken even
when the flood waters rise.
Matthew seven says, see, this is the truth.
Christ is the rock in which we can hide.
He is the one who stands between us and the enemy.
He is the one who laid his life down in between us
to pay our penalty.
He hides us like, don't think, well, I gotta go hide.
I gotta hide. He hides us. He protects us. He preserves us.
He saves us from sin. He saves us from the enemy.
He saves us from death eternally.
That is why church, that is why Hannah,
back in one Samuel two, two,
if you remember all the way back to
that point when she prayed, what did she pray?
There is none holy like the Lord,
for there is none besides you.
There is no rock like our God.
And so church with, with Psalm 95, 1 as our anthem,
let's stand together and come.
Let us sing to the Lord.
Let us make a joyful noise to the rock of our salvation.
Let's do that together.